all right shouldn't be a long video here
because this movie is a simple premise
for the simple pleasure so you get a
simple review let's get to it
[Music]
so jackass forever is the fourth jackass
movie that i never thought was going to
happen i i thought we hit peak jackass
3d we have a dildo flying across the
room smacking someone in the face in 3d
we've hit peak jackass where else can we
go yet here we are i don't know if they
have a blood pissing clause in their
contract like but do you piss blood
every day no all right gotta do another
jackass jackass four don't know but
bless these legends for doing what they
do for our amusement and that amazes me
because after doing jackass for this
long it still doesn't feel redundant
there are some bits that have the dna of
other bits that you've seen sometimes
literally but they go their own way you
know we've seen people get smacked with
the big hand before we saw that in
jackass 3d but now you have those hands
that smack people but it's if they lose
a bike race on an exercise bike that
doesn't go anywhere you know so there
are elements that are familiar but it
still feels so new just the bits and the
scenarios they do they're so imaginative
i guess that's how jackass has grown and
those were a couple of my concerns like
was it gonna feel stale was it gonna
feel redundant was it gonna feel nerfed
you know you don't want it to feel like
jackass light because like hey we're all
in our 40s we can't do this forever
let's do jackass light doesn't feel that
way there's some bits where i'm like all
right that that might actually be fun
before it really hurts like a son of a
[ __ ] other bits where i'm like
no in fact this part of the fun of
jackass for me i start quantifying like
how big would the paycheck need to be in
order for me to do that on many
occasions i'm like dude that's
i'm glad you're there to do that because
there is no [ __ ] way now this is the
first jackass movie without a couple of
familiar jackass cast members ryan dunn
because ryan dunn passed away and bam
margera there's a lot of finger pointing
as to why bam margera is not in here i
get the feeling it's
bam i hope he finds the help he needs
but there are some new cast members in
this movie now and they do their part
and they do it well it's actually neat
to see newcomers and be like i i don't
know how they're going to react to these
things like i generally know how steve-o
is going to react i generally know how
johnny knoxville is going to react
seeing new faces is welcome new
territory it gives a fresh feel to this
movie and the newcomers were there to
play they knew the job they signed up
for and it all really worked i don't
know what it was like behind the scenes
but at least on camera some scenarios
like this it'd feel like hey we gotta
haze the new guys and they would [ __ ]
with the new people more but it never
felt like that and jackass forever
everyone's a jackass equally point as i
laughed i cried but i only cried because
i was laughing so hard i was crying and
i cringed absolutely this movie has
although like cringe is just a word it's
easy to say cringe or type cringe or
meme cringe in this movie you're like oh
and you're like oh hey that's a cringe i
just
it's like when you type lol but you
don't really laugh and then when you
laugh it's different i guess it's
subjective so it'll hit you differently
maybe you will maybe you won't maybe a
different bit will hit you differently
than it hit me i will say this there's
nothing in jackass forever that grossed
me out as much as sweat suit cocktail
from jackass 3d even as i say it i'm
trying not to visualize the drinking
oh god it just did i mean there's gross
stuff in here that definitely it should
have but it it didn't gross me out as
much as sweat suit cocktail i'm just
saying the point is this jackass movie
the jackass crew they still got it
there's a part of me that was worried
about that there was a part of me that i
didn't want to watch this movie feeling
like they were those 40-something year
olds still wearing their high school
letterman's jacket where you're like
should probably hang it up by now it
doesn't feel that way there is that
element of fun unbridled fun that you
get once every jackass movie there's no
other way to stay they can't keep this
up forever when jackass is gone
it's gone and this unexpected fourth
jackass movie is a gift it has what you
want and expect from a jackass movie
i'll simply summarize like this this is
the most and the hardest i've laughed in
a movie in years jackass forever it's
worth watching it's worth buying on
blu-ray all right jackass forever have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what's your favorite bit from a
jackass movie or the biggest gross out
bit from a jackass movie or rank the
jackass movies who knows might be the
last time we get to do that but whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you